suppose marketing experts have
determined the relationship between the
selling price of an item and the
quantity sold of an item can be
represented by the linear equation q is
equal to negative 30 s plus 800 where q
is the quantity sold in a year and s is
the selling price and that makes sense
if our selling price is higher then this
whole thing is going to become more
negative and we're going to sell less
and if are we lower our price we're
going to sell more fair enough
they tell us if the cost to produce the
item is 20
what is the selling price that optimizes
the yearly profit so let's think a
little bit about what yearly profit
means
let's think a little bit about yearly
profit the profit is going to be equal
to the quantity that you sell
right the quantity that you sell
times
what times
for each unit what you care about is the
profit per unit and the profit per unit
is the selling price per unit is the
selling price per unit
minus the cost of producing that unit so
the cost of producing the unit right
there is twenty dollars minus twenty
dollars and that makes sense if you're
selling something for
say thirty dollars and it costs you
twenty dollars to make it every unit you
sell you'll make ten dollars thirty
minus twenty if you sell two units it's
going to be two times ten dollars you're
gonna make twenty dollars so nothing
really you know not nothing
groundbreaking right here
now we have right now we have profit as
a function of q of quantity and selling
price but we have quantity as a function
of selling price right here so we could
substitute we can substitute this whole
expression right here in for quantity so
what happens to our profit function then
so then we can rewrite our profit
function as being equal to instead of
writing q we could say it is the same
thing as
negative 30
s plus 800
negative 30 x plus 800 times
s minus 20. and let's multiply this out
so we have a nice clean trinomial so if
we have our profit is going to be equal
to negative 30 s times s
is negative 30
s squared negative 30 s times negative
20 that's positive
600 s 800 times s is eight hundred s
and then eight hundred times negative
negative twenty eight hundred times
negative twenty times negative two would
be negative sixteen hundred so it's
going to be negative sixteen thousand
so it's negative sixteen
thousand if i did right eight hundred
times negative twenty is negative
sixteen thousand so this right here is
our profit function and we can merge
these middle two terms right here so we
have our profit is equal to negative 30
s squared plus 1400 s just merging these
middle two terms
minus sixteen thousand now we have a
negative coefficient on the s squared
term which tells us this will be a
downward opening parabola and so let's
think a little bit about it
if this is our profit axis
that is our profit axis
and this right here
is our
selling price axis this parabola is
going to look something like this i
don't know exactly what it'll look like
but it'll look something like this it'll
be downward opening and we're asked to
find the selling price that optimizes
the yearly profit well it's optimal if
it's as high as possible so we're going
to look for a maximum point we're going
to look for that maximum point right
there find the selling point that gives
us that maximum point and we've seen
this before that's the selling point or
the s coordinate
that's the s coordinate of the vertex we
need to find the s
coordinate
of the vertex and the easiest way to
think of doing that is to kind of put
this put this function into our vertex
form so let's do that and the easiest
way to do that i could think of well
we're going to do a little bit of
completing the square and all that but
we've seen all of this before let's take
it step by step
so the first thing i like to do is
factor out the negative 30 so we have a
clean coefficient on the s squared so we
could write price is equal to negative
times
s squared
plus well actually negative so 1400
divided by negative 30
is negative 140 over 3. you can divide
both by 10
s and then 16 000 divided by negative 30
is positive
divided by 3. you take a 0 off of each
of those you have a negative divided by
negative they cancel out and that's what
we're left with and let you let me write
this positive 1600 over 3 a little bit
further out so plus
over 3. all i did so far is i just
factored out this negative 30. what we
can do now is we can add and subtract a
term here so that the first three terms
here become a perfect square trinomial
that way we can get into that vertex
form
so what do we add and subtract
well 100 negative 140 over 3 negative
140 over 3 can be rewritten as 2 times
negative 70 over 3. so what you want to
add and subtract is negative 70 over 3
squared or half of negative 140 over 3
you want to add that squared so plus
negative 70
over 3 squared and we can't just add it
to one side without doing anything else
so let's also subtract it from that same
side so minus
negative 70 over 3 squared so we really
haven't changed the equation at all
we're just adding and subtracting the
same thing to both sides but what that
allows us to do
is to make this into a perfect square
trinomial this is a perfect square
trinomial so we can rewrite our profit
function
our profit function is equal to negative
30 times this thing right here which is
a perfect square it is
s minus 70
over 3 squared and then we have all of
this business over here
minus
minus negative seventy over three
squared
plus
sixteen hundred
over three plus sixteen hundred over
three
now the next thing we can do can
redistribute this negative 30 let me
scroll down so we have some space to do
this with
so we could say price is equal to
negative 30
times this expression right here
5 minus 70 over 3. oh sorry not 5 minus
that's an s have to be very careful
that's our selling price s minus 70 over
3 squared and then we're and that's
negative 3 times this first term then we
have to multiply negative 3 times each
of negative 30 times each of these terms
so then was negative 30 times this a
negative times a negative is a positive
30 divided by 3 is 10 so it's going to
be plus
10 times negative 70 squared
10 times negative 70 squared which we
could evaluate if we want and then
negative 30 times 1600 over 3 it'll be
negative 10 times 3 it'll be negative 16
000.
negative sixteen thousand
and this is we can simplify this we can
add we could fit negative seventy
squared is what it's positive forty nine
hundred plus times ten you get forty
nine thousand
minus 16 000 which is what this is 33
so we might as well do that so this
whole thing simplifies to
our profit function our yearly profit is
negative 30
times s minus 70 over 3 squared
and let me make sure i did that right 70
times 7 times 7 is 49 and then you have
no no no it's 4 900. let me be very
clear here oh no yes 7 times 7 is 4 900
and then times 10 is 49 000 right let me
make sure i got it yup 49 000 49 000 16
000 is 33 000. so plus
just like that now when is this thing
maximized
when is this thing maximized well if you
look right here
this term right here this s minus 70
over three squared is always going to be
positive or it's always going to be
non-negative it could be 0. and so when
you multiply times a negative number
it's always going to be a negative so
this thing is always going to be
non-positive
non-positive it could be equal to 0. so
the profit is going to take its highest
value when this whole expression is zero
and when is this whole expression going
to be zero well the whole expression is
going to be zero when s is equal to
seventy over three
when s is equal to
seventy over three that's when it equals
zero and just we have a better sense of
that what is 70 over 3 so that is what 3
goes into 70 3 goes into 7 2 times 2
times 3 is 6.
bring down a to get a 10 3 goes into 10
three times three times three is nine
subtract and then you get another ten so
it's 23.333333
you could view it that way it just keeps
repeating
or you could say the ideal selling price
is
23.33
so the ideal selling price
the maximum selling price the selling
price that optimizes our profit
the selling price that optimizes our
profit is 23. and 33 cents and when you
do sell for 23.33
this is going to be zero that whole
thing is going to be zero and your
profit is going to be 33 000
so that point your profit is going to be
dollars for the year